avec les cigarettes électroniques.
Il est temps d'agir,
d'avoir des réglementations
qui remédient à l'attrait et à l'accès à ces appareils par la jeunesse.
Les fumeurs ont-ils vraiment besoin de 15 000 goûts adaptés aux enfants
pour arrêter de fumer ?
Ont-ils besoin de tant de types d'appareils ?
Est-ce une bonne idée d'avoir des appareils si faciles à cacher
et si faciles à utiliser ?
Nous avons récemment entendu
que la FDA prévoit d'instaurer des réglementations plus strictes
sur la vente de ces appareils contenant des liquides aromatisés
dans les magasins
tels que les magasins de proximité et les stations-service
ainsi que sur la vente d'appareils à des mineurs via internet.
Cela suffira-t-il à changer la croissance rapide de l'adoption par la jeunesse ?
Nous devons poser et répondre à ces questions cruciales.
Il est aussi temps d'avoir une sérieuse campagne de sensibilisation.
Les ados et leurs parents doivent savoir
que si les cigarettes électroniques
contiennent moins de toxines que les cigarettes,
elles ne sont pas bénignes.
L'exposition de leurs corps aux produits chimiques produits par ces appareils
pourrait les changer de façons qu'ils n'apprécient pas
et les vouer à des toxicités et problèmes de santé futurs et inconnus.
Quand j'ai dit plus tôt
que la cigarette électronique convenait à la génération des smartphones,
je ne plaisantais pas.
Nous vivons dans un monde passionné par la technologie,
où les derniers gadgets et technologies reçoivent beaucoup d'attention
car c'est de la technologie et c'est le truc le plus récent.
De plus en plus au cours des années à venir et pour le reste de notre vie,
nous allons voir des technologies arriver sur le marché
qui n'alerteront pas tout de suite quant à notre santé,
simplement car elles ne paraîtront pas malsaines
ou ne seront pas des dispositifs médicaux.
Par exemple, nous pourrions voir des appareils
permettant de tenir plus longtemps sans dormir
ou nous aidant à perdre du poids -- un objectif personnel --
ou d'atteindre un certain nombre d'autres objectifs
qui intéressent beaucoup les consommateurs.
Mais nombre de ces appareils pourraient comporter des risques inacceptables
pour notre propre santé.
Si nous voulons protéger notre santé et celle de nos enfants,
peut-être devrions-nous perdre l'habitude
d'automatiquement célébrer de telles nouvelles technologies
et prendre l'habitude de les considérer d'un œil critique,
peut-être même d'un point de vue médical.
Car vous savez quoi ?
Notre santé, la santé de nos enfants et celle des générations futures
est bien trop précieuse pour la laisser partir en fumée --
ou même en aérosol.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)